all right y'all welcome back JY Ridley
is here our next guest is another
business woman and the star of her own
reality show Vander pump rules new
episodes air Tuesdays on Bravo and
streams starting the next day on peacock
please everybody Welcome Lisa
vanderp
[Music]
[Applause]
I understand that Bel Buckle is very
Texan I like it you came out all I saw
yeah that's all I saw I was like that's
wonderful have yall met each other
before no but we're Brits and we both
went to boarding school I was
watching yes L common and I speak French
so I can teach you French oh
my sexy woman wow oh dualingo would love
you um so how how you have a new
grandson is this exciting yes well he's
two years and two months and it is the
best thing that ever happened to me he
he is just everything and you know I get
so emotional talk about it because I
loved my children so much and I didn't
know how it was going to be yeah and
then he was was here and I just cannot
believe it didn't happen sooner because
it's the best thing and he calls me
Nanny
pinky Nanny pinky Nanny Pinky and all I
wanted for Christmas cuz it's just you
know starting speak was to call me Nanny
Pinky and sure enough on Christmas Eve
he said I love you Nanny Pinky and that
was it that was it I I couldn't have
asked for more I couldn't I love well
the best part too is that you get to
send them home with your kids I think
that's why it's so enjoyable
it is knowing you have that option but I
don't like sending him home I love him I
mean Pandora is very very you know kind
of Hands-On mother yeah but I I just
it's no coincidence that I live a 100
yards around the corner as well oh
that's wonderful yeah maybe she doesn't
think
so who cares now you have a new
restaurant it's called wolf right yes I
named it after him his name is Teddy
wolf um and it's opening in Lake Tahoe
in a couple of weeks if get back there
and and do what I'm supposed to be doing
but very W yes well it's just called
wolf it's no I said his name Teddy wolf
that's a very great name yeah well they
talked about his second name being bear
and I was like no no if he's going to be
United States President he cannot be
called teddy bear
so don't
know think about so yeah the new
restaurant's called wolf and it's it's
exciting with another one with Caesar's
Palace yeah you is this the third third
and then I'm opening the fourth which
will be named after me pink P my
nickname and it would be pinky by vaner
pump in the flamingo so yeah it's super
super busy that's
amazing why that's my restaurant um in
Paris Casino and we designed it in in
Caesars yeah and it was just I think
voted like the 10th or 11th restaurant
uh most photograph restaurant in the
United States so so cool you are so
successful at it love it so much no I'm
just saying like you you what is it
about Vegas because you keep open they
wealth because you keep making money at
it probably no no but it's like it's
Vegas I think even more so since the
pandemic you know it was very hard for
restaurant ters and 100,000 100 more
than that closed down in America and my
hat goes off to anybody that managed to
keep their business of FL CU it was a
real really you know a struggle um but I
think Vegas is just so vibrant now and
people really go there I love I go there
to do shows it's fun CU you go in and
out yeah yeah great food I don't go in
and out I go and I stay there I love it
yeah oh I'm usually in and out I like I
want a good meal some great coffee and
I'll give a show that's my that's my do
you love Vegas do you love going there I
actually we took my mom for her 60th
birthday and but what was hilarious was
I was so tired cuz I had been shooting
and someone bet me to ask for a hot you
know they'd like do your drink orders on
the thing yeah like someone said I'll
give you 50 bucks if you order hot
chocolate I was like okay so there I was
like betting cards is drinking my hot
chocolate oh could been worse could have
been a couple first of all exactly yeah
there was some Amarula in there just
saying yeah it's a good day uh so so
your new season of Vander pump like ruls
like what what's going on what's a tease
for us it was so complicated you know
and it kind of blew up out of the
stratosphere I mean it was just so crazy
it was a lot of bad behavior the season
before and we tried to sort it out but
we'd stopped filming when it was all
exposed so we need this season this
season feels very very different to any
other season to sort it out and as the
kind of matriarch do you ever watch the
show you're looking at me like maybe you
do no I'm I'm just fascinated by
everything you do I'm like like what
don't you do it's insane oh there's a
couple of things how my
[Laughter]
husband it's the British humor I I have
so many jokes
they're so wasted right now God I wish
this was a nighttime show well we need
another commercial break everybody watch
Vanderpump rolls Tuesdays on Bravo and
streaming on
[Music]
[Applause]
peacock thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going
home